few child actors have had a life story
as Redemptive as I Carly's Janette
mccartie though her TV days are over her
life was forever changed by the show for
better or sometimes worse becoming a
child star was never an aspiration for
Janette mccartie but rather for her
mother Deborah mcer alleged that it was
her mom who had wanted to become an
actor but when those dreams didn't
happen Deborah relentlessly pursued that
dream with her daughter mcc's childhood
home life was also troubled she was
homeschooled in a religious household
her parents constantly fought and her
mother was a compulsive hoarder mccartie
said that most of the obsessive Behavior
was attributed to her mother's health at
the time in janette's infancy her mother
was diagnosed with breast cancer the
actor said that her mother began living
vicariously through her and sent
mccartie into the world of child acting
Deborah also routinely examined her
daughter's body for signs of cancer
among other troubling behaviors that
deeply traumatized mccartie it became
difficult for the Nickelodeon star to
challenge her mother's Authority as she
would often remind mcer how lucky she
was for her early success on I Carly in
her Memoir I'm glad my mom died mcer
writes that Deborah would constantly
tell her everyone wants what you have
the pressure on Janette mccartie only
got worse the more successful I Carly
became desperate to keep up appearances
on television mcc's mother taught her to
develop an eating disorder when she was
only 11 years old as mccartie later
recounted in a red table talk with Jada
pinket Smith her mom was the one who
encouraged her to restrict calories we
were just in the disease in the sickness
but there was a connection that the
sickness created that I of course
couldn't see at the time mccc's
struggles with anorexia and bulimia
followed her into iic Carly and Beyond
she was limiting herself to under 1,000
calories a day in an attempt to make her
mom proud even after the death of mcc's
mother the eating disorder grew worse
with the actor at one point collapsing
in co-star Miranda Cosgrove's bathroom
many child stars from Disney Channel and
Nickelodeon have attempted music careers
after the success of stars Selena Gomez
and Miley Cyrus in her 2022 Memoir I'm
glad my mom died MCC revealed that when
I Carly was shut down due to the 2007
wga strike her mother pushed her into
pursuing country music in 2009 she
signed a record deal with Capital
Records turning down an offer from
Taylor Swift's then home label big
machine records after releasing several
singles and DPS MCC released her debut
self-titled album in 2012 but mcc's
music career didn't last long as the
Nickelodeon star ended up leaving
Capital Records because of a commitment
to her new I Carly spin-off show Sam and
Cat mccartie expressed regret over her
country music days in her Memoir though
the brief stint offered one huge shift
in her life Deborah's cancer returned
and mcer was able to go on tour without
her it was the first time the two were
separated since mcer was a young child
but her solo Excursion ended up creating
more guilt for mcer she told the
guardian in 2022 God did it feel to feel
relief that I'm going to be away from my
mom for the first time when my mom also
was just diagnosed with cancer and was
dying Nickelodeon's I Carly ended its
run in 2012 though Janette MCC didn't
stray far from the network in its
immediate aftermath in 2013 the actor
starred in a spin-off series with Ariana
Grande Sam and Cat when mccartie
initially signed on to the show she was
under the impression that it was meant
to be a solo series for her character
Sam Pucket Nickelodeon instead developed
it to include Grande's character while
filming Sam and Cat things started to
spin out of Janette mcc's favor at the
network she revealed in her Memoir that
Grande was consistently given
preferential treatment on the program
missing entire weeks to pursue her music
career mccartie was forced to turn down
several film offers due to her
contractual obligations to Salmon Cat a
standard Grande was not held to mccy has
since softened towards Grande in recent
years she told vogan 2022 I'm able to
look back on it and just see it as the
comedy gold that it is to be on set at
21 where you're just the most
susceptible to jealousy and comparison
that you can possibly be and I'm there
across from a burgeoning pop star of the
day oh
oh is it that bad no you barely notice
it a good portion of Janette mcc's
Memoir I'm glad my mom died recounts her
experiences with the Creator a pseudonym
for I Carly and salmon cat Creator Dan
Schneider Schneider's Behavior was
common knowledge by the time of the book
release Nickelodeon severed ties with
him in 2018 and he has since been
accused of verbal abuse and sexual
misconduct mcc's Memoir only added fuel
to the fire she claimed that he
intimidated her into underage drinking
among other inappropriate actions he
committed towards her she wrote The
Creator is doing the thing that I've
heard from my co-stars he does with
every new star of a show that he's
making he takes you under his wing
you're his favorite for now mccartie
began to rely heavily on alcohol due to
the stress and abuse she was facing she
opened up about her relationship with
alcohol for the first time in a 2020
episode of her podcast empty inside as
if the treatment Janette mccartie faced
from Nickelodeon on I Carly and Sam and
Cat wasn't enough the actor was also
Limited in her opportunities outside of
the network aside from having to Turn
Down movie offers due to Nickelodeon
related commitments mcer instead began
making appearances in similar projects
on Nickelodeon her guest spots on other
popular Nickelodeon shows included True
Jackson MVP and Victorious while her
frequent appearances got her nominations
at the Teen Choice Awards and Kids
Choice Awards there was little career
benefit the older she got it wasn't
until after I Carly and Sam and Cat were
over that mccartie branched out to more
serious roles she appeared in the 2016
Thriller Pat and most notably the
Netflix drama between in which she
starred for two seasons in 2018 she made
her directorial debut with a short film
Kenny which premiered on YouTube short
of the week mcer was especially proud of
the project having assembled an all
female crew to help her make it mcer
didn't have the benefit of leaving
Nickelodeon on good terms she stated in
her Memoir that the network offered her
$300,000 to stay quiet about her
experiences with Dan Schneider though
she ultimately turned the hush moneyy
down she briefly regretted the decision
these days she's proud that she chose
the path of morality rather than caving
to the network that exploited her the
death of Janette mcc's mother Deborah
was a pivotal moment in the young
actor's life her mother died in 2013
just 3 years after receiving word that
her cancer had returned when mcer was
only 21 years old even without the
Monumental figure in her life
controlling her every decision it took
years before mcer could reconcile with
the Damage Done mcer believes the kind
of healing she was able to do wouldn't
be possible with her mother still alive
stating that therapy wasn't an option at
the time even when she finally started
to seek help it was a long road to
figure out how she really felt she
recounted on The View that it was tough
going to the first first therapist she
saw where she said you know what you're
describing is abuse and I left I quit
therapy I couldn't tolerate the idea the
notion that my mom was abusive mcer
takes great pride in her ongoing mental
health Journey what she credits to
unpacking years of emotional and
psychological abuse at the hands of her
mother in 2014 Samm and cat was
cancelled after one season ending
Janette mcc's 7-year tenure on
Nickelodeon a lifetime's worth of trauma
had occurred to the actor during that
time but within a year she would make
the first steps toward shaping the rest
of her career mcer began with creating
writing and starring in her own web
series what's next for Sarah the
autobiographical four episode show finds
MCC playing Sarah whose hit tween TV
show is cancell throwing her life in
disarray as she tries to figure out what
to do next the cast of what's next for
Sarah starred many Nickelodeon friends
of mcer including Mary Shear Shane top
and Danielle Maro the show is mccc's
first opportunity to Grapple with what
her career and entertainment has meant
on her own terms she's continued to
write and create art about what's
happened to her while simultaneously
pursuing a career that has kept her far
away from her Nickelodeon past there are
one too many stories in Hollywood of
child actors being taken advantage of by
the adults in their lives mcer was no
different given the extreme control
exerted on her life and career by her
mother while mcc's acting success was a
fulfillment of her mom's lifelong dream
to be a star there was also a practical
purpose for it through her acting gigs
Janette became the bread winner of her
family supporting her parents
grandparents and three older brothers
but mcer didn't receive any of the money
she earned working as an actor her kugan
account which is meant to shave off 15%
of the salary a child actor makes into a
savings account was never properly filed
as a result mcer is unaware of what
happened to all of the money or where it
went but it's believed to have been
stolen by her mom mccc's hard work paid
off in other regards later in life in
202 2 she released her New York Times
best-selling Memoir all about the abuse
she suffered from her mother mccartie
confirmed that her older brothers were
in favor of her decision to speak out
she told The Hollywood Reporter my
brothers have been so supportive so
understanding they get the title to put
it simply in 2020 MCC debuted her first
one woman show I'm glad my mom died
which was her most vulnerable work to
date she was initially hesitant about
performing the show herself though she
eventually realized that only she could
tell her own story The Stage Show ran
only for a few months at the start of
2020 before the covid-19 pandemic shut
down Live Theater during the pandemic
mcer continued to the conversations
about her past on her podcast series
empty inside with guests like Anna
Ferris Mike Berbiglia and Daniel SLO she
opened up about her mom her relationship
with alcohol and her career after
Reviving The one woman show in 2021 she
turned her story into a memoir in 2022
I'm glad my mom died sparked lots of
media attention as she came forward
about the abuse she suff suffered from
both her mother and Nickelodeon I think
that anything worth saying is probably
going to be divisive I think if it's not
divisive it's probably there's probably
no new conversation to be had there the
book almost immediately sold out on
online retailers and remained at number
one on the New York Times bestseller
list for 8 weeks mccartie has since
signed a new deal to write books for
penguin random house she told the New
York Times felt like finally I'm saying
my words and saying things I want to be
saying I'm myself mcc's life has been
quite the roller coaster ever since she
was first cast on iic Carly in 2007
though she's been through a lot of
unimaginable tragedy and harrowing
trauma MCC has come out on the other
side stronger and braver in 2021
Paramount plus made the decision to
reboot I Carly bringing back Miranda
Cosgrove Nathan Crest and Jerry trainer
to reinhabit the characters they had
last played in 2012 but mccartie said no
thank you she described in her Memoir
that Cosgrove contacted her personally
to invite her to reprise the role of s
Pucket despite Cosgrove's encouragement
mccartie refused to return not wanting
to retread the experience that caused
her so much pain throughout her life
Nathan Crest later addressed mcc's
absence on his own podcast radioactive
dads saying I think it's just a personal
decision and where she's at and what she
wants to do mccartie has stated that she
doesn't miss the experience of being on
I Carly one bit she knows she's plenty
busy with her book deals her new podcast
hard feelings and her plans for writing
and directing if you or anyone you know
may be the victim of child abuse or
sexual assault contact the relevant
resources below the childhelp national
child abuse hotline at 18004 a child
1800 422 4453 or contact their live chat
services